The concept is that if you sink into a chaotic state of being, and everything falls apart,
then there is the possibility that you can get things back on track,
including what you have just learned,
in a new capacity.
You can imagine that symbolically as the existence of the deceased father at the bottom of the Landscape of Chaos,
That is the right way, as far as I am aware, to think about it.
It is as if there is something down there that has the capacity to recover and rise again.
It is as if this entity incorporates the previous state of affairs and takes it further.
And you will not find that unless you descend to the chaotic valley,
where the feeling comes over you that all order is gone.
If you generate order, it will be similar to the order you had before
but it will also have new aspects.
It is ergo:
down to the bottom of the chaotic permutation of circumstances to bring up what you miss.
And that is one analytical level.
You think: a different analytical level ...
That is also what you do ...
What you should do when you are in college ...
You come to the university in roughly the same capacity as Pinocchio;
you're a bit of a puppet, and kind of a minkukel,
and what the hell do you know?
It is chaotic because you have not yet completely found your place in the world.
And I don't just mean career,
- not that it is completely irrelevant, because it is indeed important -
but it is more important than just the fact that you have not yet achieved a career;
since you are a historical creature, for you are a result of history.
Unless you are properly cultured,
which means that you have a deep understanding of your past,
in the sense that the humanities can arm you with that understanding,
then you have failed to incorporate the wisdom of your ancestors into your daily activities.
And that is going to make you weak.
At least that's the idea.
So when you come to college ...
This is the purpose of the university:
it exists so that you can throw yourself in the chaos and extrapolate something valuable from it.
And you can incorporate that into your own personality,
and that makes you immensely more unruly.
"More unmanageable" than in literally more uncomfortable, not simply "higher educated".
It is not that you know more facts, it is that you are literally a better person.
'Better' means: you can do many more things, you can articulate yourself better ...
That is something that is crucial, that you can properly articulate yourself.
That is more convenient than anything that you could possibly achieve.
If you have earned your Bachelor / Master,
with the skills to formulate coherent arguments and use language correctly,
then you own the toolbox to be so influential that it is bizarre.
Regardless of the circumstances ...
You can always prepare a strategy and execute it successfully.
And perhaps the strategy is oriented towards something good, something that will seriously work.
Work for you and at the same time work for others.
I don't really understand why this is not being told to people when they come to college.
Your goal is to make yourself as eloquent in writing, and thinking, and speaking as you can.
Because that opens the door to everything you want to do in the future, regardless of what it is.
The better-discussed individual always rises up.
Always.
Because ... that visualizes strategies more effectively,
it deconstructs the reasons for doing something or not in a more specific way,
it convinces people.
Moreover, it does not convince people thoroughly.
He can effectively deal with potential that lies in the perspective.
He can defend himself against criticism.
That all goes to the past - to the chaos of the past, you could even say -
and it pulls the Esprit that lives in it up from the bottom, and becomes one with it.
And if you don't ... Well ...
then you stand powerless against the Tragedy of Life.
And that is not so good, because if powerless is confronted with the Tragedy of Life,
then you will be harmed much more than you would have if it had turned out differently,
and ditto for the people around you.
And then the probability that you will be resentful and bitter about it is very high,
because nobody likes to fail successively.
And then you become bitter and resentful.
From the moment you are bitter and resentful, the next step is to be revengeful and mean.
It does not require much transformation to move from one phase to the next.